i want to talk to you today about what
i'm calling the nexus the intersection
of immoral and stupid
and when i hear the nexus of immoral and
stupid
i think about a handful of members of
congress and on that list is republican
matt gates
matt gates is voting against capping
insulin prices to the end user now it's
crazy to use the term end user when
we're talking about
medicine i agree with you it's also a
crazy situation because
we are only talking about capping the
price of insulin for the end user so
late last week the house of
representatives passed a
democratic-sponsored bill
to cap insulin at 35 a month for most
americans in terms of their
out-of-pocket now of course you know and
i know and anybody who's dealt with
health insurance knows these things cost
way more but health insurance will pay
part of it and then there's a discount
and
i i know some of you were sick of this
example but it's been at least six
months since since i've made an example
when i had my infamous appendectomy you
might remember that the sticker price
was 35 grand
now that's what the hospital billed my
insurance
my insurance had said
sirs and mams at the hospital we know
people sometimes have appendicitis
will you contract with us for
appendectomies
for i believe it was eleven thousand
dollars so of the thirty something
thousand that the hospital wanted
my insurance said
we
are okay with 11
and i had a 2 000 deductible so the 35
000 appendectomy ended up being 2 000
for me
and my insurance made up that other nine
thousand dollars similarly with insulin
you know there are people now who pay
over a thousand dollars a month
in the price the actual price of insulin
msrp sticker price wouldn't even change
with this bill but the point here is
insulin guys insulin
35 a month let's cap it and matt gates
says no why does matt gates say no
basically because people should just
lose weight he wrongly thinks
not that it would really make a big
difference but he wrongly thinks only
overweight people need insulin matt matt
gates sang quote
while democrat posturing of h.r 6833
victimizes insulin payees as people with
an uncontrollable disease that are being
taken advantage of and need big brother
to throw them a raft
lifestyle changes and mass
would expeditiously lower demand and the
subsequent prices of insulin
90 to 95 of people with diabetes have
type 2 which can be prevented or delayed
with healthy lifestyle changes such as
losing weight eating healthy food and
being active
arbitrary price controls are no
substitute for individual weight control
since 2000 the number of diabetes cases
in the u.s has nearly doubled the demand
for insulin has increased and the
requisite price increase has followed
suit in other words the price of insulin
increases as waistlines increase so yes
he's a prick yes of course
but he's also ignorant aside from this
being asinine and disgusting and just
horrible
it's not accurate
type 1 diabetes
is managed by taking insulin to control
blood sugar
type 2 diabetes
in
more ways than type 1
is managed in other ways
this means medication
this means exercise this means diet when
i say medication i mean a pill not
insulin
people with type 2 diabetes
sometimes are prescribed insulin but
insulin is about type 1 diabetes insulin
is for type 1 diabetes who are often
perfectly fit
it is for type 1 diabetes for people who
are
not overweight
and there's a couple of different things
here and
i don't even know where to start to be
totally honest guys i mean on the one
hand
should absolutely no condition related
to our own actions be covered because
then we're saying we're not covering
lung cancer most of which is related to
cigarette smoking
we're not covering
injuries that happen as a result of what
we might call
extreme sports or risky activities
we're not covering covet stays for
people who are unvaccinated i mean so
first of all is this idea that i mean
listen i want people to live as healthy
a lifestyle as possible but are we
really saying we shouldn't be covering
costs for people who have certain
conditions because of how those
conditions develop that seems very very
dangerous number two now as i've said
before people will say but david sir
didn't you say that
if we have a full er
and you need to start putting coveted
patients on ventilators
it seems okay as part of triaging
limited resources to say the vaccinated
people get the ventilator first
because they're more likely to survive
and they're more likely to follow
medical directions as to their care that
is different than saying you're just not
covered if you have type 2 diabetes so
that's number one number two you know
we've talked before about obesity seen
as a basically a moral failing so
putting aside that insulin is mostly for
type one and matt gates is talking about
type two
this idea that we can only see we should
only see obesity as a moral failing
is uh is wrong at the same time it
should be okay to say that in the united
states lack of uh nutritional education
leads people to eat persistently
unhealthy diets for their entire lives
and we've got to be able to talk about
that as well but when we talk about
obesity we're talking about
sometimes diet sometimes genetic factors
sometimes underlying disease there's a
lot of different things and again seeing
obesity as the big moral failing also is
extraordinarily myopic so
uh
and the fat shaming and stuff like that
does not appear to work matt gates is
disgusting
insulin should be cheap to the end user
maybe we call them the end customer or
whatever the case may be and he's vile
for voting against this and he's vile
for his reasoning as well
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below